the Public Health Service it's people
and programs affect the lives of
millions of Americans every day whether
it's a matter of medical research pure
food and drugs contagious diseases or
the delivery of health care the Public
Health Service plays a significant role
how the Public Health Service became
what it is today
is really the story of Public Health in
America a story that is still unfolding
[Music]
throughout the years the Public Health
Service has fought its battle in
plague-ridden cities and in the
corridors of power in Washington today's
public health service agencies are
challenged by an ever-changing world and
they respond the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention strive to protect
citizens from infectious and
non-infectious diseases the health
resources and services administration
supports the training of health
professionals and sends them to
underserved areas the National
Institutes of Health conduct basic
research on diseases such as AIDS the
Food and Drug Administration hastens the
approval process to bring new drugs to
the public the substance abuse and
mental health services administration
provides services for mental behavioral
and addictive disorders the
health-related concerns connected with
hazardous wastes are increasingly
important and are the responsibility of
the agency for toxic substances and
disease registry a relatively recent
addition to the PHS is the agency for
healthcare policy and research the
agency strives to assess the
effectiveness of medical care the Public
Health Service also responds to needy
members of the community providing care
to Native Americans through its Indian
Health Service it also assists the
elderly drug addicts those with AIDS and
others who might be forgotten when it
started its mission then as well was to
serve a group that had little access to
medical care merchant seamen
that was in 1798 when an act of Congress
signed into law by President John Adams
provided for the government to maintain
hospitals for sick or disabled seamen as
had traditionally been done in England
[Music]
for its first 80 years or so what was
then known as the marine hospital fund
was administered by customs inspectors
in the seaports of the new nation as the
United States grew so did the number of
ports marine hospitals and clinics
sprouted on the East Coast as well as
the West Coast and up the Mississippi
anywhere there was a waterway in the
growing nation by 1870 the system needed
to be revamped the reorganization led to
the appointment of the first Surgeon
General John Maynard Woodworth
he had been an army medical officer in
the Civil War Woodworth put his officers
in uniform created a flag and instituted
the military system of appointment by
merit
dr. Woodward's reforms were formalized
by law in 1889 when the Commission core
of the US Marine Hospital service was
created as the commissioned Corps was
expanding during the closing years of
the 19th century so was biological
discovery the scientific ferment brought
changes to the marine hospital service
it's hygienic laboratory started in 1887
was a pioneer in biomedical research it
manufactured biologicals and trained
scientists from state health departments
in the techniques of producing them
years later it became the National
Institutes of Health the heart of
American medical research in the latter
part of the 19th century the marine
hospital service was given another major
responsibility boarding vessels arriving
at US ports to check passengers and
crews for infectious diseases this task
had originally been handled by the
states
but as emigration mushroomed the
responsibility was transferred to the
federal government at all ports of entry
the marine hospital service was in
charge of inspection of arriving
immigrants including the most important
of them of all Ellis Island
the surface pioneered the line it was an
efficient way to check for immigrants
with disease blindness and mental
deficiencies anyone who might become a
public charge more than 12 million
immigrants as many as 5,000 a day at
times passed through Ellis Island under
the examining hands and watchful eyes of
the marine hospital service in 19 - the
service was renamed it became the public
health and marine hospital service in
1912 as legislation increased its scope
of activities its name was simplified to
the Public Health Service in the early
1900's the service led to fight in
investigating dozens of diseases and
developing treatments for them the
service battled trachoma a serious
contagious eye disease that can cause
blindness commissioned Corps dr. John
McMullen took his team to the rural
hills and hollows of Kentucky he
established a hospital and 11 field
clinics
[Music]
McMullen and his team taught personal
hygiene to local residents to stem the
spread of the inflammation within ten
years the incidence of trachoma cases
was drastically reduced the PHS
marshaled his energies in Montana's
Bitterroot Valley to combat Rocky
Mountain spotted fever the disease was
carried by ticks on livestock and other
animals PHS dr. Thomas McClintock was
sent to Montana to find a way to control
the disease as he searched for a cure he
became infected with the disease and
died dr. McClintock was one of five PHS
officers who died from Rocky Mountain
spotted fever a vaccine to combat the
disease was ultimately developed one of
the most perplexing diseases of the time
was pellagra five thousand people a year
were dying from it in the early years of
the century PHS physician scientist
Joseph Goldberger carefully studied the
disease visiting the orphanages and
prisons where pellagra struck most often
most doctors believed the disease
resulted from infection convinced of his
own theories Goldberger and his wife had
themselves injected with the blood of
those who had the disease his findings
were startling poor diet not infection
caused pellagra soon pellagra was
conquered by inexpensive dietary
supplements the core pioneered treatment
of tuberculosis and bubonic plague
control at risk to their own safety
officers fought the battles in the
laboratories and in the communities as
well in San Francisco and other cities
the officers work to vanquish the
culprits in bubonic plague rats and
ground squirrels and their fleas
energetic cleanup campaigns over the
years led to the control of the dreaded
plague venereal disease particularly at
the time of World War one was a major
concern
the surface developed tests and public
education campaigns and ran research
centers like this one in Arkansas
workers took on child health as a
responsibility to PHS personnel traveled
throughout the countryside of America
examining and inoculated youngsters
against diseases such as typhoid and
then there was the matter of keeping
vital statistics early work and
biostatistics kept staffers busy this
was the personal computer of the
twenties the compilation and
interpretation of statistics relating to
health and disease involved the PHS then
as now at the center of PHS work in the
20s and 30s was disease control and
rural sanitation many and officers
attention was occupied with privies
there were the good ones the bad ones
and the worst ones along with evaluating
privies the service designed built and
distributed toilets the bottom line was
good outhouses worthy of the approval of
the Public Health Service like this one
bearing the PHS C
during those years the service
successfully battled with dozens of
infectious diseases including malaria
typhus yellow fever and hookworm during
the 20s and 30s the marine hospitals
remained the core of the Public Health
Service the hospital's employed the
majority of PHS personnel and served as
a training ground for physicians
dentists and other clinicians as the 30s
wore on and the nation struggled its way
out of the depression the Public Health
Service became part of the cure the
Social Security Act of 1935 was landmark
legislation providing the PHS with the
authority to make grants to help develop
and improve state and local health
departments the Surgeon General at the
time dr. Thomas Perrin was an ardent
publicist for the health causes of the
day he made syphilis prevention one of
the mainstays of his mission his
outspokenness on the subject led to more
public attention to venereal disease and
its prevention his conservative
predecessor Surgeon General us coming
had served four terms in the position
and generally opposed PHS assistance in
local health matters in 1936 President
Franklin D Roosevelt relieved coming as
Surgeon General and appointed Perrin the
longtime public health officer the
essence of FDR's New Deal resonated with
Perrins considerably broader view of
public health during the Roosevelt
administration 55 acres in then rural
Bethesda Maryland
became the new home of what had
originally been the hygienic laboratory
in 1930 the laboratories name had been
changed to the National Institute of
Health the move to Bethesda prepared the
NIH for its period of rapid growth in
the post-war years
19:41 saw the country's entry into World
War two Public Health Service officers
served in several different branches of
the Armed Forces
many were assigned to the Coast Guard
and did everything from making Seabourn
house calls while on convoy patrol to
supporting amphibious landings perhaps
one of the most fundamental changes
brought about by the war was in nursing
the strain of war on the country's
healthcare system made it clear that
something had to be done to increase the
supply of nurses the answer was the
cadet Nurse Corps which was formed to
meet the need women enrolled in nursing
schools and received a free education
they were paid a salary by the PHS and
were obligated to perform military or
Federal service in return for their
education 85 percent of the nurses
graduated in the years 1943 to 46 were
in the cadet Nurse Corps the quality of
nursing education was changed forever as
a result of PHS policy and funding
nursing schools were no longer in the
shadow of hospitals which had previously
been their sole sponsors it was a
tremendous boost to the profession the
PHS is most important legacy from World
War two was the Atlanta based malaria
controlled in war areas program often
referred to as the MCW a malaria control
was a major activity in the American
South and the Caribbean during the war
at the end of the war it became clear
that the M CWA had developed an
important role in infectious disease
research and control so it was continued
providing practical applications of
Public Health for search techniques to
problems such as typhus control the
agency remained at its atlanta base and
was renamed the communicable disease
Center and later as we know it today the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention with a greatly expanded role
CDC handles everything from highly toxic
viruses to quarantine expertise for the
space program along with the valuable
work of the CDC PHS dentists like H
Trent Lee Dean were making major
contributions to the nation's health in
the 1940s 95% of the population suffered
from tooth decay but in some parts of
the country people had low levels of
decay though their teeth were modeled
and pitted
PHS researchers in the field and the
labs were the prime detectives in
solving the case
NIH Dennis determined that the teeth
were mottled because of elevated levels
of fluoride in drinking water and that
fluoride led to a reduction in tooth
decay in 1945 Grand Rapids Michigan was
the first city to test this proposition
at 4:00 p.m. on January 25th 1945 Grand
Rapids began adding fluoride to its
water supply
schoolchildren actively participated the
results were astounding fluoride in the
water reduced dental caries by as much
as 60% fluoridation became the principal
public health strategy in the prevention
of tooth decay since the early 1900's
dental and medical care for Native
Americans had been provided by PHS
personnel on loan to the Indian field
service but in 1954 an act of Congress
transferred formal responsibility for
the health of American Indians to the
Public Health Service it was the hope
that a program administered by health
professionals could improve the health
of Indians that proved to be the case
by 1960 Native American infant mortality
had declined by almost 25% and the death
rate from tuberculosis by almost 50%
today that program is an agency of the
PHS the Indian Health Service public
health physicians also serve the need of
another often forgotten sector of the
population prison inmates since 1930 PHS
officers have worked with the Bureau of
Prisons its facilities and hospitals
environmental health issues surfaced in
the 40s in steel towns like Donora
Pennsylvania smog made six thousand
people ill and killed another 120 along
with air pollution concerns about water
pollution were mounting as well
radiation in the atmosphere from nuclear
testing was apparent the PHS began to
study radiation and its biological
effects environmental health concerns
have stayed on the scene growing in
prominence within the CDC public health
teams deal with toxic substances and
since the 70s the National Institute for
Occupational Safety and Health has dealt
with a myriad of industrial and
environmental issues post-war
development in biomedical research paid
rich dividends and led to nobel prize
honors for dozens of investigators
supported by NIH grants for NIH
scientists have been Nobel laureates
Marshall nirenberg for breaking the
genetic code julius axelrod for his work
on the central nervous system
Christian enfin s'en won a chemistry
prize for work on amino acids and
Carlton gotcha SEC for isolating a virus
fatal among natives of New Guinea as
reflected in dr. Gallo sex work
International Health had become an area
of importance for the PHS one with
notable successes the CDC for instance
provided leadership for the global
campaign that resulted in the conquest
of smallpox in 1967 Surgeon General
William Stewart had pledged PHS
personnel to the World Health
Organization campaign against smallpox
more than 300 PHS physicians scientists
and public health workers led by the
CDC's dr. da Henderson went all over the
globe to fight the battle and they won
by 1977 smallpox had been eradicated
throughout the world in the 1960s
reorganization brought new programs to
the PHS fold one of the most significant
was the Food and Drug Administration
which had been an independent agency
since its inception in nineteen six its
original responsibility was for the
protection of the American consumer
against adulterated or mislabeled food
and drugs
[Music]
today the agency set standards in the
areas of food drugs cosmetics radiation
health and medical devices the agency
has labored to expedite and improve the
approval process for new drugs
reorganization in the early 1970s
established the PHS in its essential
form of today one of those changes was
bringing programs for mental and
addictive disorders together into one
agency today the substance abuse and
mental health services administration
administers prevention and treatment
programs in these areas while research
activities and mental health and
substance abuse are carried out by the
National Institutes of Health during the
1970s the PHS became heavily involved in
the delivery of health services to poor
isolated populations the community
health center program supported more
than 800 health centers throughout the
country and provided medical care
workers to these communities through the
National Health Service Corps these
programs remain a vital part of the
Public Health Service today as the needs
of the medically underserved continue to
grow the health resources and services
administration supports both state and
community efforts to serve those who are
less fortunate and provides health care
practitioners to staff those systems
[Music]
the organization continues to support
the education of health professionals
through scholarships and training
programs to assure the quality and
effectiveness of Health Services the
agency for health care policy and
research has been established it
sponsors health services and medical
outcomes research toward the goals of
improving the practice organization
financing and delivery of healthcare
services the PHS has led the national
and global battle against HIV and AIDS
carrying out primary research on the
virus and sponsoring prevention and
treatment programs throughout the
country all of the agencies of the PHS
are engaged in this monumental public
health campaign the Public Health
Service is made up of both Civil Service
and commissioned corps members in
addition to staffing the agencies of the
PHS the commissioned Corps provides
clinical and scientific personnel for
the Bureau of Prisons the Coast Guard
the Environmental Protection Agency and
the National Oceanographic and
Atmospheric Administration in the 1980's
Surgeon General C everett Koop captured
the public eye bringing visibility to
health issues with his outspoken reports
on AIDS and smoking today the Public
Health Service is part of the Department
of Health and Human Services and the
heads of its agencies now called
operating divisions report to the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
the assistant secretary for health and
the Surgeon General advised the
secretary on health policy and programs
the operating divisions of the Public
Health Service provide clinical care
while protecting the consumer through
regulation of Food Drug and medical
devices
the service also continues to conduct by
a medical and behavioral and health
services research throughout the United
States and around the world
[Music]
the PHS maintains its tradition of
public health campaigning with its
healthy people program to promote health
awareness and public action throughout
the United States
and the service continues its scientific
and public education battle against the
epidemic of disease caused by tobacco
with a wealth of achievements and a
proud history the Public Health Service
protects and advances the health of the
American people it does so with its
special blend of science and government
tradition and topicality public service
and personal commitment its work
continues to respond to the
ever-changing mandates of science the
dictates of government and the needs of
the people
[Music]
this videotape is based on the book
plagues and politics the story of the
United States Public Health Service
written by dr. Fitzhugh Mullen